hello hello
hello hello sabrina nice to meet you
guys congratulations on the movie
thank you so much for watching so i got
a question for both of you to start for
the folks out there who do not have a
jazz in their life and are convinced
they can't dance for [ __ ]
like me what advice would you give them
i think anybody can the only limitation
you put is on yourself
everybody can get up and dance and have
a good time i say that dance is a
universal language it's your body
language and if you've got one
you can move it so i think yeah don't
tell yourself you can't you can't do a
girl
yeah it really is therapeutic and i
think especially for like
quinn's journey throughout the movie of
like someone who's like knows that she
can't dance and gets to a place where
like she knows that she's still not the
best but it's fun like it's
it's just the act of doing it in the act
of doing it with people you love and
people to bounce off of and
um it brings a really good energy it
gets you in your body and it gets you
very present which is important right
now
well my little cousins demanding a tick
tock dance video soon so now i kind of
have no choice
demand no longer we we have we're going
to deliver
tell them to do a tick tock challenge to
let me love you by sabrina carpenter uh
in the movie working
tis the plan so kind of on the flip side
of that
you are both insanely talented but over
the course of your careers if not your
lives have you ever
tried to pick a skill that you thought
you could never do in a million years
and you actually managed to pull it off
for me it was recently and it was
broadway um
it was it was not something that i never
thought that i could ever do but i
definitely didn't know i was ready to do
it at this point in my life being
you know just turned 21 i i i expected
that to be something
down the road um and so it was it was
something that i worked really hard
at and wanted to accomplish and i only
got to accomplish it for a short period
of time before
the pandemic but um but i hope to get
back to it eventually
yeah i always forget that in these
interviews i'm also babysitting her
because she's such a
we we lad she's so young um and has
accomplished so much so i think um
working with her is something that i
didn't know
if i could do it especially um
but you know it ended up working out and
we ended up working it but i think a
dream of mine for a long time has been
to be in a dance movie straight
up be in a dance movie and i don't think
you're ever you ever think you're ready
for your dream to come true
it just comes true and you just live and
be present
and take that box and gotta add more to
the list now yeah
so yeah i'm glad i'm excited for people
to watch it
sabrina going back to the uh the
broadway thing um
is that something you are hoping to
return to and what would you say
you learned about the production of
putting on a broadway show that
surprised you
no my goal was to only ever do two shows
on broadway
published it surprisingly no yeah i mean
i cannot even believe that it's
it's you know it's something that has
been
you know introduced to my world and and
i'm so grateful that to be a part of the
show that i was a part of which was mean
girls
i absolutely hope to to come back to it
when it comes back i hope that broadway
returns as soon as
as soon as it's safe um but but it's
it's such a
it's such a really really beautiful
experience for anyone who's i've i've
have so many friends that have never
seen a broadway show and it blows my
mind because i just feel like
the way that you leave the theater is
the way that i hope people leave uh
their netflix accounts watching this
movie um because it really does leave
you in such a great
mood in high spirits and feeling
inspired and feeling like you want to
be in your own broadway show or being
your own dance movie and um i think
those are the best kinds of things to be
a part of
oh absolutely this is probably a weird
connection to make but liza having come
from your beginnings with vine is there
anything about the
super short form content that you find
yourself
actually you know thinking back to when
you do something like a feature film
not a weird connection at all i totally
see where you're going with it um
the six seconds of it all taught me how
to speak
in quick verb verbiage
like tell me how to like create these
little blurbs of these little one liners
which
definitely fuels and feeds all of the
content that i've ever created
since you know starting on vine whether
that be youtube and the quick blurbs
there
or coming onto set and allowing being
allowed to
dance freely literally and figuratively
of like improving on set and just giving
these quick lines a lot of the lines
that you see in the movie was just
me talking out of my butt thank you so
much laura to russo
um but our director she was amazing and
allowed us to just have fun with it
so i think yeah i think it was like a
training camp i've been like
growing and evolving all these different
ways to amount up to this
moment of being in a dance movie and and
having the most fun with it
you could totally tell with your with
your comedic timing i feel like
i i really thought that i picked up on
that but didn't know
i was just pulling that out of thin air
is there an example of a line that you
came up with
on the spot commercial oh my god it's
one of my favorite lines in the movie
she goes you look like a pokemon
commercial and it's
so funny i don't know why i think it's
just because it was such a spot-on
reference but like
she's so full of those and i don't know
where they come from like she'll just
say stuff and then
me off and then i have to react but in
character and then i never know what i'm
in store for
um yeah oh my gosh
bless you it came out of my you didn't
sneeze but i just wanted to bless you i
don't know i feel you
yeah yeah um but it just it came out of
like my own training camp of like i
didn't go
to you know acting school or comedy
school or group classes
you were born gifted is that what you're
trying to say i'd say that directly but
you did so thank you for that
um but i think i have my own training
camp online i think that's what a lot of
people are doing right now too
in this kind of quarantine is you're
faced with your own self and your own
boredom and you're trying to entertain
yourself and
i think a lot of entertainers are going
to be born out at this time so i'm
excited to see what happens
i totally would agree with that
entertain yourself and also like maybe
actually have the guts to try a new form
of content creation that you might not
have had if we weren't all stuck at home
right now so
yeah always reaching for the silver
lining um
sabrina the last time we spoke it was
for the hate u give
which i think about all the time and i
was wondering
is there anything you learned from
working with amandla on that set
about being number one on the call sheet
that you take to your your own movie
wow i mean you picked like a perfect
person as
as someone that led by example and
someone that i learned so much from
because she just like
handled that movie and the weight of
that film with such grace and ease and
um and and yeah made everyone feel feel
really together and
i hope to do the same thing going into
to any project that i do whether i'm you
know
i'm the lead or i'm not a lead i think i
think it's it takes a village of people
and i think it's important to remember
that and
um i think the most important thing is
knowing that
you can't do it all by yourself and
every single person
on set has a reason and a purpose to be
there and to appreciate each other and
to
understand each other and to recognize
each other's hard work and
um i think that that was something that
i definitely learned from a mandala but
also just like observing her she's just
a wonderful
really really kind-hearted person so um
so yeah
i have a lot of i think very fondly of
her and just that whole
filming experience in general was one of
the most beautiful things i've ever been
a part of
with that idea in mind of it taking a
village to make a movie if you both had
to pick an
unsung hero from the crew
of work it who would you pick another
one oh wow
that is not like eddie's everyone
deserves a participation ribbon
and a first place trophy because
everybody just won my heart working
together on this film like there's some
there's so many like new actors
that didn't even know there were actors
until they stepped on to set and like
by that i mean like we we had toronto
dancers come in and play these
roles of our of our friends and in our
dance group
and they're dancers first but now actors
for the very first time and i'm so
excited for people to see them and their
friends and their families to see them
in a new light
because they gave it they really just
they delivered they served so i'm just
excited
they're so talented and like not to
mention like our choreographers that
were being like
hit with like new information every five
minutes like oh we need to change this
entire number this is a completely
different song
actually we've got this part and we have
to move this here and like just always
like handling it with like
okay that's what we're going to do and
like you don't want to make an
environment like that feel more stressed
so the fact that they were so
professional
and handled it like just just like the
professionals they are i mean
but like again like we could go as far
as hair makeup
wardrobe uh camera crew our
cinematographer deepano
toronto literally the entire city of
toronto our director obviously our
producers that were like
there every step of the way like it
would it would be so unfair to choose
one um because they were all so
important
i feel like you feel those good vibes
come through in the finished product i
can't wait to go watch it with my little
cousin this weekend
yes or next weekend we're gonna watch
the movie and then we're gonna make a
tick tock video i promise
thank you guys again and congratulations
thank you so much
good to see you